Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the clubetsina is still flowing. The party is continuing into the small hours. In Copenhagen, in Stockholm, in Oslo, in Reykjavik, the tears are flowing at the end of what has been an extraordinary festival of divine sport. Yes, this has been the week of the Rest is History World Cup of Gods.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。美酒仍在流淌。派对正延续至凌晨。在哥本哈根、斯德哥尔摩、奥斯陆和雷克雅未克，神圣体育盛会落幕之际，泪水夺眶而出。是的，这就是“历史的余烬”诸神世界杯之周。
Tom Holland, have you enjoyed yourself? I've enjoyed it so much. I think it truly has been a festival of divine sport. But I think that I should mention for the benefit of those who may have absolutely no idea what you're going on about, I think you're hallucinating. This week on on twitter we've been holding um a world cup of gods where people vote for in a knockout contest um we are speaking
汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Holland），你过得开心吗？我太开心了。我认为这确实是一场神圣体育的盛会。但我觉得我应该向那些完全不知道你在说什么的人说明一下，我觉得你产生幻觉了。本周在推特上，我们一直在举办一场诸神世界杯，人们在淘汰赛中投票选出……我们正在录制
in the aftermath of the final uh dominic's given some hefty clues there as to who made the final but we won't announce the results and what we'll do is we'll go through the first 16. So we've got eight group matches there. And we'll talk about each match, discuss the God that got knocked out. And then we'll go through the quarterfinals, semifinals to the final, discussing each God in turn. So lots of divine sport to look forward to. But Dominic, first of all, I think we should dedicate this episode to the person who made it all possible, who was your son, wasn't it? Yes, my nine-year-old son.
在决赛结束后——多米尼克在那里透露了一些关于谁杀入决赛的重大线索，但我们不会公布结果，我们要做的就是回顾前十六强。我们有八场小组赛。我们要讨论每一场比赛，谈谈被淘汰的神明。然后我们再从四分之一决赛、半决赛一直聊到决赛，逐一讨论每一个神明。所以有很多神圣的体育内容值得期待。不过多米尼克，首先，我觉得我们应该把这一期节目献给让这一切成为可能的人，也就是你的儿子，对吧？是的，我九岁的儿子。
So we did a World Cup of British Prime Ministers, which was quite interesting in revealing what, well, Twitter users who listen to the rest of history think about Britain's prime ministers anyway. And my son thought this was quite an amusing but ultimately quite boring exercise and said, why don't you have a World Cup that people would actually care about, which is one of ancient gods? And so we did. And it has been good fun. There's been a lot of controversy about who we... So my son's favourite god is Horus
我们之前做过一期英国首相世界杯，这挺有趣的，因为它揭晓了——嗯，至少是那些收听《历史的余烬》的推特用户对英国首相们的看法。我儿子觉得这挺有意思，但归根结底是个相当无聊的练习，于是他说：“你们为什么不办一个人们真正关心的世界杯，比如古代神明世界杯呢？”于是我们就照办了。这确实很有趣。关于我们……所以，我儿子最喜欢的神是荷鲁斯（Horus），
and we never even picked Horus. Tom, would you like to explain our rationale for the gods that we did and didn't pick? Yeah, so we didn't want to cause needless offence. So we didn't want to have gods that people are still worshipping, appearing in Twitter polls and getting knocked out by dog-headed Prince Philip and so on. So the specification was that only those gods were eligible that at some point over the course of history had ceased to be worshipped.
而我们甚至根本没选荷鲁斯。汤姆，你想不想解释一下我们选择和没选择某些神的逻辑？好的，我们不想引起不必要的冒犯。所以我们不想让人们仍在崇拜的神明出现在推特投票中，然后被顶着狗头菲利普亲王之类的人淘汰。因此，我们的筛选标准是：只有那些在历史长河中的某个时刻已经不再受到崇拜的神明才有资格入选。
So Odin, for example, is still worshipped by a few people but there was a point where nobody worshipped him right so so um yes so a temple to odin has just opened in iceland i think um but that's kind of very recent likewise in greece there are shrines to the olympians but again they're kind of late 20th century resurrection. So basically it's dead gods. Okay. And I think that that's interesting for the number of gods that therefore didn't make it. So gods from India, from China, from Japan. So places where there's more continuity, I suppose you could argue.
所以，比如奥丁（Odin），现在仍然有少数人崇拜他，但在历史上曾有一个时期是谁都不崇拜他的，对吧？所以……是的，冰岛刚刚开了一座奥丁神庙，我想……但这可以说是非常近期的事了。同样，在希腊也有供奉奥林匹斯众神的圣地，但它们也属于20世纪后期的复兴。所以基本上，这就是死去的神。好的。我认为这很有趣，因为许多神因此没有入选——比如来自印度、中国、日本的神。这些地方的神明传承可能更具连续性，你可以这么认为。
Absolutely. So there's been a lot of talk on the sports forums, obviously, about this tournament. And here is Olly O'Connor with a kind of very interesting point that with this draw, we're guaranteed an Olympian in the final. So he's dwelling on the way that the Greek gods basically dominate the entry lists, highlighting once again their stranglehold on the fan base
绝对是的。显然，体育论坛上关于这次锦标赛有很多讨论。奥利·奥康纳（Olly O'Connor）提出了一个非常有趣的观点：通过这次抽签，我们确保了决赛中必有一位奥林匹斯神。他谈到了希腊神明基本上主导了参赛名单的方式，再次突显了他们对粉丝群体的垄断
over the past 600 years. Throw in an egyptian and norse god as the others and it begs the question how do we grow or diversify the game and again john midgley is his continued eurocentricity will do nothing to calm the fans that the tournament is as ever being stitched up for the big money tv markets of ancient greece and the early viking period there's a serious answer to that though, isn't there, Tom? That the way you would diversify the game is by people no longer worshipping Asian gods or Chinese, Indian, whatever. I mean, the reason we probably didn't include them is not just because we're European, so
在过去600年里。再加上一个埃及神和一个北欧神作为其他代表，这就引发了一个问题：我们该如何发展或使这项运动走向多元化？同样，约翰·米德利（John Midgley）指出，这种持续的欧洲中心主义，根本无法平息粉丝们的担忧，即这项赛事一如既往地是在为古希腊和早期维京时期的庞大付费电视市场暗箱操作。不过汤姆，对此其实有一个严肃的回答，对吧？你发展这项运动的方式，就是让人不再崇拜亚洲神明、中国神明、印度神明或别的什么。我的意思是，我们之所以可能没有把他们纳入其中，不仅是因为我们是欧洲人，所以
we tend to be more interested in Europe. I mean, that's what we studied at school. But also because having a tournament with Ishtar and Kibaleh and Lockheed and Dionysus, you're not going to offend anybody because they're all defunct. They've all been superseded by monotheism, which is not the case of some of these others, presumably. I mean, the interesting and serious point to be made here is the way that Christianity andlam have operated as kind of neutron bombs incinerating gods so it's it's europe the near east where christianity and islam have have really established themselves there is no place for other gods and so they've all gone although tom isn't it might be not discuss this during the podcast that that a lot of these gods actually or at least some of
我们往往对欧洲更感兴趣。我的意思是，这是我们在学校里学的。而且也是因为，如果举办一场有伊什塔尔（Ishtar）、西布莉（Cybele）、洛基（Loki）和狄奥尼索斯（Dionysus）参与的锦标赛，你不会冒犯任何人，因为他们都已经过时了。他们都被一神教所取代了，而其他一些神明则显然不是这样。我的意思是，这里有一个有趣且严肃的观点，那就是基督教和伊斯兰教如何像中子弹一样运作，将神明彻底焚毁。所以，在基督教和伊斯兰教真正确立了自己的欧洲和近东地区，已经没有其他神明的容身之地了，所以他们都消失了。不过汤姆，我们在播客里讨论过，其中许多神明实际上——或者至少有一部分——
them have in various ways been incorporated. Well, yes. And that's what actually I found fascinating about this, sort of reading up on all the gods, is the extent to which some of them blend into each other and then they all ultimately flow into what we think of as the invaders that destroyed them. Well, so there were two particularly controversial participants in the last 16, Moloch and Bridget,
以各种方式被吸收融合了。嗯，是的。这也是我在阅读这些神明资料时觉得最着迷的地方，那就是其中一些神明相互融合的程度，以及它们最终都融入了我们所认为的摧毁它们的入侵者之中。嗯，所以在十六强中，有两个极具争议的参赛者：摩洛克（Moloch）和布丽吉特（Bridget），
both of whom may not even have been gods. Yeah, may not have existed, whereas, of course, all the others did exist. Yeah, well, let's not get into the theoretical. So Moloch and Bridget were both included. I think you would agree that there was some opposition from you to my pressing for them. I didn't mind Moloch because I liked the child eating.
这两位甚至可能根本不是神。对，可能根本不存在，而其他所有人当然都是存在的。好吧，我们别陷入理论探讨了。所以摩洛克和布丽吉特都入选了。我想你会承认，当我坚持要选他们时，你曾表示过一些反对意见。我不介意摩洛克，因为我喜欢吃小孩的桥段。
Bridget, I just thought, frankly, I mean, I'd never heard of Bridget. So I was very scornful. And in fact, there were a few people on Twitter who weighed in on Bridget and were like, what? How have you picked somebody nobody's ever heard of? But one for the Irish fans. One for the Irish fans. There was some debate about, I mean, even my wife, who is Irish, said,
至于布丽吉特，坦白讲我只是觉得……我的意思是，我从没听说过布丽吉特。所以我对此非常不屑。事实上，推特上确实有一些人对布丽吉特发表了看法，觉得：“什么？你们怎么选了一个谁都没听说过的人？”不过这是为爱尔兰粉丝准备的。为爱尔兰粉丝准备的。当时有一些争论，我的意思是，甚至我那身为爱尔兰人的妻子也说：
who the hell is Bridget? Right, well, we'll come to Bridget and we'll find why I think that she was a worthwhile candidate. But should we come to the first match of the group stages, which was Zeus against Moloch? Well, Moloch is a great god, I think, because he's got everything you want from a god. What is he?
“布丽吉特到底是谁？”好吧，我们会聊到布丽吉特，并探讨为什么我认为她是一个值得入选的候选人。不过，我们是不是该进入小组赛的第一场比赛了？那就是宙斯（Zeus）对阵摩洛克。嗯，摩洛克是个伟大的神，我认为，因为他具备了你对神明的所有期望。他是什么？
He's mentioned in Leviticus. He's Canaanite, so Phoenician. And he's involved with child sacrifice. So he sort of ticks the boxes of what you assume a generic ancient god will be but he may not even have existed at all am i right tom he may just be that's right so so very so moloch essentially seems to have been the ritual of child sacrifice yeah and so therefore it is contested whether what is being described in in the old testament is a god or a ritual
他在《利未记》中被提及。他是迦南人，也就是腓尼基人。他与献祭儿童有关。所以他基本上符合你对一个普通的古代神明的所有刻板印象。但他可能根本不存在，我没说错吧，汤姆？他可能只是……没错。所以，摩洛克本质上似乎只是一种献祭儿童的仪式。因此，旧约中描述的究竟是一个神还是一种仪式，目前仍存争议。
because basically the old testament is the only evidence that we have for it. So this is, they have what, they're tophets, tophets, or whatever they're called, where they, there are these altars where you sacrifice children. Is that right? Well, again, which is, I think only mentioned it in the Old Testament. And it seems to be a shrine in a place called Gehenna, which is a valley near Jerusalem, where we're told child sacrifice happens.
因为基本上，旧约是我们拥有关于他的唯一证据。所以，他们有所谓的“托斐特”（Tophets）圣地，也就是祭祀儿童的祭坛。是这样吗？嗯，同样，这似乎只在旧约中被提及。它似乎是耶路撒冷附近一个叫欣嫩子谷（Gehenna）的地方的一座神龛，据说那里会发生献祭儿童的事。
Yeah. But again, it may be a more kind of general description for a place where child are offered up to a god. What I found fascinating reading about this is, am I right in thinking that these sacrifices may actually have been made to the god of Judaism, to Yahweh? So, for example, Abraham and Isaac, that that story may be a sort of remembered version of the sacrifices that were happening. So the question is, if Moloch was not a god, if it's a description of a sacrifice what to what god were these children being sacrificed um there's a passage in jeremiah where he says that it's to to baal who is the
是的。但同样，这可能只是对一个将儿童献给神的地点较为笼统的描述。我阅读相关资料时觉得最着迷的是，我这样理解对吗：这些献祭实际上可能是献给犹太教的神——耶和华（Yahweh）的？例如，亚伯拉罕和以撒的故事，可能就是对当时正在发生的献祭的一种记忆留存。所以问题是，如果摩洛克不是神，如果这只是对一种献祭的描述，那么这些儿童究竟是被献祭给哪个神的呢？耶利米书里有一段话，他说那是献给巴力（Baal）的，巴力是
great god of the canaanites um the kind of king of the canaanite gods i wanted baal in the tournament but i know you did i know you did but we're discussing baal under under the rubric of mollon yeah but i've got baal's got him got a name check uh barl of course is you know the great rival of of yahweh the the god of the jews becomes the god of christians as well um but what you also get in jeremiah is kind of first person commentary from yahweh insisting that he did not demand child sacrifice yeah and there's a possibility that he's slightly protesting too much right that's a strong thing to say about god tom uh you know so jeremiah 19 5 something this is something i did not command or mention nor did it even enter my mind right you think well okay there's something's something very Boris Johnson about that, isn't there?
迦南人的伟大神明，可以说是迦南众神之王。我本来想把巴力纳入锦标赛的，但我知道你想……我当然想。但我知道，我们在摩洛克的名义下讨论巴力。不过我还是让巴力被提及了。巴力当然是耶和华（犹太人的神，后来也成为基督徒的神）的伟大对头。不过你在耶利米书中也能看到耶和华的第一人称评论，他坚称自己从未要求过献祭儿童。是的，而且有一种可能是他有点此地无银三百两了。对吧？汤姆，对神说这样的话可真够犀利的。你知道的，比如耶利米书 19章5节：“这不是我所吩咐的，不是我所提说的，甚至这从未进入过我的脑海。”你会想，好吧，这……
Slightly. So then if actually the Old Testament bears witness to the kind of buried memories of these rituals, and I think there's quite a lot of evidence that aspects of cultic worship that are condemned by the Hebrew prophets may actually have been applied you know these were cultic practices associated with a figure of yahweh so cleaning up their own religion yeah slightly yes i think so and moloch has become a symbol of that to some extent well sacrificing a child is obviously controversial for us because we're the heirs of of that yeah that that tradition
这非常有鲍里斯·约翰逊（Boris Johnson）的风格，不是吗？有点像。所以，如果旧约确实见证了这些仪式被埋没的记忆，而且我认为有相当多的证据表明，希伯来先知们所谴责的那些邪教崇拜的某些方面，实际上可能被应用过——你知道，这些是与耶和华这一形象相关的邪教习俗——也就是说他们在清理他们自己的宗教？是的，我想是的。在某种程度上，摩洛克已经成了这种现象的象征。嗯，献祭儿童对我们来说显然极具争议，因为我们是那个传统的继承者。
that moral heritage absolutely repellent i mean we we view it as as highly you know what the most disgusting thing that you can do um but there's a you know there there is evidence i think as you said with with um the sacrifice of you know abraham being asked to sacrifice isaac and then of course shadowing it the the way in which there's a sense that God in the Christian tradition is sacrificing his son. Or there's some, so there are kind of echoes, perhaps, of the relationship of father and a son and the son being sacrificed that perhaps goes back to this. I mean, obviously, these are very contested issues and very deep waters. But the other thing, I think the other thing moving away from the purely biblical is that there is evidence as well for this happening from classical authors.
那种道德遗产，简直令人作呕。我们认为这是极其……你知道的，这是你能做出的最令人作呕的事情。但有证据表明——正如你所说，随着亚伯拉罕被要求献祭以撒——当然，随之而来的暗示是，在基督教传统中，上帝牺牲了自己的儿子。或者说某种程度上，存在着父亲与儿子以及儿子被牺牲的关系的回响，这种关系也许可以追溯到这一点。我的意思是，显然这些都是极具争议的问题，水很深。不过，除了纯粹的圣经记载之外，另一件脱离纯粹圣经的事情是，古典作家也留下了这方面的证据。
And is this in Carthage? Are we moving on to Carthage now? Well, there's evidence from a guy called Philo of Byblos, who is writing in the first century AD, who says that basically the people of Phooenicia would do this that the kings would sacrifice their children and they would do it as not because they wanted to get rid of their children but but precisely the opposite the children are the most precious thing to them and so therefore that is what you offer the gods in in a desperate situation because yeah only if you offer something that's absolutely precious to you there's a great scene of this in have you ever read uh flobear's novel salon bus um where there's a huge scene isn't there where
这是发生在迦太基吗？我们现在要转到迦太基了吗？嗯，有一个叫比布罗斯的斐洛（Philo of Byblos）的人留下了证据，他在公元一世纪写作时说，腓尼基人基本上会这样做，国王们会牺牲自己的孩子。他们这样做不是因为他们想抛弃孩子，而是恰恰相反。孩子们对他们来说是最珍贵的东西，因此在绝境中，这就是你献给神明的东西，因为只有献出对你而言绝对宝贵的东西……在福楼拜（Flaubert）的小说《萨朗波》（Salammbô）里有一个很棒的场景，
they um they sacrifice all the children in the punic war they're fighting uh that's not the punic war is they're fighting some mercenaries yes they're fighting mercenaries after the first punic war uh and isn't hannibal is spared hamilcar sends another child instead of hannibal or something and hand was spared so that he's going to fight clearly the Romans later on. And so there was a lot kind of an assumption that this was Roman propaganda and perhaps that it wasn't true. But they have you know, there is archaeological evidence for it. They have found kind of cult centers where there's evidence for child sacrifice. And there's a brilliantly creepy illustration from a cemetery, a kind of shattered tower in a Punic cemetery,
里面有一个宏大的场景，对吧？他们在布匿战争中牺牲了所有的孩子……他们当时在战斗——等等，那不是布匿战争，是他们在与雇佣兵作战。是的，他们在第一次布匿战争后与雇佣兵作战。汉尼拔（Hannibal）不是被饶了一命吗？哈米尔卡（Hamilcar）用另一个孩子代替了汉尼拔，所以汉尼拔被放过了，以便他日后能与罗马人作战。因此，曾有很多假设认为这纯粹是罗马的 propaganda（宣传），也许并非事实。但他们确实有考古证据。他们发现了存在儿童献祭证据的礼拜中心。从一个墓地里还流传着一幅极其诡异的插图，
Phoenician cemetery, Carthaginian cemetery on the coast of Spain, where there's a baby in a bowl being offered to this kind of two-headed monster uh who's holding a pig right what's the pig what's the pig gonna where's the pig gonna come i don't know it's all i mean that's that's the other thing there's so much we don't know and it's all just incredibly weird and very i think very sinister so perhaps we should put that up um yeah i. I think maybe when we link to this on Twitter or something, we could put a picture of that thing, because it's very, very creepy. And so I think that I'm not surprised that Moloch got knocked out.
那是西班牙海岸的一个布匿墓地、腓尼基墓地、迦太基墓地里的一座破损的塔楼，图里有一个盘子里的婴儿正被献给一个手里拿着猪的两头怪物。那个猪是干嘛的？猪是从哪儿冒出来的？我不知道，所有这些……我的意思是，这就是另一回事了，有太多我们不知道的事情，这一切都不可思议地诡异，而且我觉得非常阴暗。所以也许我们应该把这个……是的，我想也许当我们在推特上发这个链接时，我们可以放一张那个东西的照片，因为它真的非常非常诡异。所以我对摩洛克被淘汰并不感到意外。
Yeah, I was about to say, Moloch got knocked out. Pretty horrible. But he also has a starring role in uh paradise lost um horrid king besmeared with the blood of human sacrifice and parents tears milton's not messing around is he no no and i think that does kind of haunt the imagination still so i think that even though mollock may not even have existed i think that he deserved his place but i i wasn't surprised to see him go out so let's move on to another um another another forward at the first hurdle chippy totech chippy totech was up against odin now chippy totech was another of yours you were very keen on chippy yeah uh he's
是的，我正要说呢，摩洛克被淘汰了。相当可怕。但他在《失乐园》（Paradise Lost）中也扮演了重要角色：“丑陋的国王，涂抹着人祭的鲜血与父母的眼泪”。弥尔顿（Milton）可真是一点也没手软，对吧？没有，没有。而且我觉得那幅画面依然在人们的想象中挥之不去。所以尽管摩洛克可能根本不存在，我认为他配得上自己的位置，但我看到他出局并不感到意外。所以让我们进入下一个……另一个在前几关就被淘汰的前锋：奇皮托特克（Xipe Totec）。奇皮托特克的对手是奥丁。现在，奇皮托特克又是你的主意，你对奇皮托特克非常热衷。
he's a colorful character there's a lot of sacrifice going on with him he's aztec he's from what the 14th, 15th century. Tell us about Chippy Totec, Tom. Well, we discussed him briefly in the episode with Camilla Townsend on the Aztecs. And I mentioned there how years ago there was an exhibition on the Aztecs in the Royal Academy, and there was a statue of Chippy Totec there. And he looked rather adorable because he had kind of bubbles all over him.
他是一个色彩鲜明的人物，他身上有大量的献祭。他是阿兹卡人，来自14或15世纪左右。汤姆，给我们讲讲奇皮托特克吧。我们在采访卡米拉·汤森（Camilla Townsend）关于阿兹卡人的那一期节目中简短地讨论过他。我当时提到，多年前皇家艺术学院举办过一场关于阿兹卡人的展览，那里有一尊奇皮托特克的雕像。他看起来相当可爱，因为他身上到处都是小泡泡。
So he looked like a children's character. Yeah. You know, a lovable cartoon character. It's like a Michelin man, almost. Yes, a little, yes. A bit more bubbly than that. Yes, yes. Kind of, you know, the inside of an Aero,
所以他看起来像个儿童卡通角色。是的。你知道的，一个讨人喜欢的卡通角色。几乎就像米其林轮胎人一样。是的，有点像。比那个更多一些泡泡。是的，有点像……巧克力威龙（Aero）里面的那种结构，
kind of chocolate bar, little bubbles of chocolate. Maltesers, teasers. Yes. But actually what these bubbles are, are the deposits of fat of the inside of a flayed skin. Lovely. And Chippy Totec is known as the flayed one. Because what he does is he skins himself. And by doing that, he is giving food food to humanity so he's the god of fertility
那种巧克力棒，一小块一小块的巧克力气泡。玛采沙（Maltesers）巧克力豆。是的。但实际上这些气泡是剥皮人内部脂肪的沉积物。太美妙了。奇皮托特克被称为“剥皮者”。因为他做的事情是剥下自己的皮。通过这样做，他正在把食物赐予人类，所以他是生育和农业之神。
and agriculture his festival is in the spring it's all about the way that the earth gives forth new life from death and all those kind of rituals but it's done in a very, very terrifyingly literal way, because increasingly, and we heard again that from Camilla Townsend, that as the Aztecs, Aztec power grows and grows, so the rites of sacrifice grew and grew. And prisoners are skinned and the priests of Chipitotec then wear these skins for 20 days. They must have stunk. I mean i mean the stench horrible i mean but and after 20 days they put them in pots and let them rot away and these pots have kind of special seals so they don't smell i wonder whether this so chippy totech i discovered from my reading was also associated with pimples rashes and eye infections and i wonder whether that was because i mean if you go around wearing somebody else's skin for 20 days you're going to develop i mean your own skin will be in a poor condition presumably afterwards i guess that that would be
他的节日是在春天，这一切都关乎大天化育、万物从死亡中焕发新生以及所有诸如此类的仪式。但这是一种非常、非常可怕的字面意义上的做法，因为正如我们再次从卡米拉·汤森那里听到的那样，随着阿兹卡人的权力越来越大，牺牲的仪式也越来越多。战俘被剥皮，然后奇皮托特克的祭司们会穿上这些皮20天。那一定臭气熏天。我的意思是，那恶臭简直可怕。我的意思是……而且20天后，他们把这些皮放进罐子里让它们腐烂，这些罐子有特殊的密封所以不会发臭。我不知道这……我从阅读中发现，奇皮托特克还与粉刺、皮疹和眼部感染有关。我在想这是不是因为——我的意思是，如果你到处穿着别人的皮走上20天，你肯定会感染……我的意思是，事后你自己的皮肤状况大概会变得很糟糕吧。我想那会是原因之一。但我认为，我们在所有这些神明身上看到的现象，显然也是让他们成为世界杯上有价值的竞争者的关键部分——那就是他们既能进攻也能防守。他们既能带给你好处，也能带给你灾难。他们通常是由对我们来说似乎是对立的元素复合而成的。所以绝对地，奇皮托特克为人们提供生存所需的食物，但他也可能会给你带来严重的眼部感染，或者让你长满青春痘之类的。
part of it but i think also what we see with all these gods and it's obviously a crucial part of what makes them worthwhile contenders in the world cup is that they they can do offense and defense that that they they can do you they can do you good and they can do you evil yeah and they're a compound of often of what seems to us opposites and so absolutely chippy um provides people with the food that they need to survive but it give you a bad eye infection he will give you all spots or something. Yeah. I mean, that's such an incredibly banal detail. I'm amazed.
是的。这是一个如此令人难以置信的平庸细节。我太惊讶了。我的意思是，居然能想到眼部感染之神。这绝不会是我显而易见能想到的。我现在用完全不同的眼光看待阿兹卡人了，既然我知道了这一点。但也有这样一种感觉，即更深层次的感觉——我们讨论过奇皮托特克的祭司喜欢用刺刺自己的生殖器。当然。我觉得如果《历史的余烬》里没有一些日后会出现的身体肢解桥段，那就不是完整的一期节目了。
I mean, to think of the god of eye infections. Well, wouldn't strike me as an obvious. You know, I see the Aztecs in a very different light now that I know that. But there's also the sense, you know, the deeper sense that, and we talked about how the priests of chippy um like to stab their penises with thorns of course yeah and i don't think it's an episode of the rest of this through unless we've got some mutilation coming
其实是的，我们有相当多的生殖器肢解内容，但我们早早就切入了这个话题。所以阿兹卡人确实有这种感觉：除非你向神明献上鲜血，除非神明饮用鲜血，否则黑暗将威胁整个世界。这也是大多数这些古代宗教的共同点，对吧？我的意思是，这显然是一种普遍的人类信仰。我们可能比较不寻常，因为我们不相信。我的意思是，好吧，我想，甚至在基督教传统中，也有“喝这血”的说法。
up later actually yeah we've got quite a lot of genital mutilation but let's get in there early um and so the aztecs did have they had the feeling that unless you were offering blood to the gods, unless the gods were drinking it, then darkness would threaten the whole world. Yeah. And that's kind of common across most of these ancient religions, right? I mean, that's clearly a universal human belief. We're probably unusual in not believing. I mean, I think, well, I suppose, but even in the Christian tradition, you know, drink this blood.
是的，还有耶稣为我们流血。所以，神圣鲜血的概念是不变的。同样，我认为这也将贯穿这场比赛的始终。对于一个色彩斑斓、充满异国情调的神明来说——如果这种说法听起来不算太“东方主义”的话——他的表现非常糟糕，我是这么觉得的。
Yes, and Jesus shedding his blood for us. Yeah, so the idea of divine blood is a constant. And again, something I think that we'll see running throughout this contest. Well, for a very colourful, exotic God, if that doesn't sound too sort of orientalising, he performed very poorly, I thought. Well, he was up against Odin, wasn't he?
嗯，他的对手是奥丁，不是吗？
Yeah, he was. But even so, I thought the flayed one, the skin and all that, I thought that would win him a few brownie points. But possibly doesn't have cut through. Clearly not. I mean, and this is kind of why the gods, you know, the major gods are talking about setting up a Super League. We've just got to hope that they don't go through with that. Because I think it is important.
是的，他是。即便如此，我以为“剥皮者”、人皮以及所有那些元素能为他赢得一些同情分。但可能并没有引起共鸣。显然没有。我的意思是，这也是为什么众神——那些主要神明正在谈论建立一个超级联赛。我们只能希望他们不会真正付诸行动。因为我认为这很重要。
He just didn't resonate with, you know, he's this Keir Starmer of Aztec gods. I really don't think that Chippy Totec and Keir Starmer are a natural fit. But I think, you know, as Ollie O'Connor said, it's important to grow and diversify the game. Yeah. And, you know,
他只是没有引起共鸣……他是阿兹卡诸神中的基尔·斯塔默（Keir Starmer）。我真的不认为奇皮托特克和基尔·斯塔默是天作之合。但我认为，正如奥利·奥康纳所说，让这项运动发展并走向多元化是很重要的。
a World Cup of Gods in which you have Aztecs seriously competing has got to be a more exciting cup. I wanted to have Hernán Cortés. But we know
而且，你知道，一场阿兹卡人严肃竞争的诸神世界杯，肯定会是一场更激动人心的杯赛。我本来想让埃尔南·科尔特斯（Hernán Cortés）参赛的。但我们知道
that he wasn't a god, no. Well, I know, but I mean, there was some doubt at some point, wasn't there?
他不是神，对吧？
Anyway, let's move on. Next god. Are we going to do, should we do Is there was some doubt at some point, wasn't there? Anyway, let's move on. Next god. Are we going to do... Should we do Ishtar next? We've got, yes, Mithras against Ishtar. So this was a nice one because this was an all-Asian clash, really, wasn't it? Well, we might discuss that.
我知道，但我的意思是，曾经有一段时间存在某种疑问，不是吗？
Whether Mithras really is a Persian god. Yes, okay. But Ishtar is definitely a Mesopotamian god. So are you a fan of Ishtar? I actually wasn't bothered about Ishtar, but once I read up on Ishtar, I thought she was very interesting.
无论如何，我们继续吧。下一个神。我们要不要……我们应该把伊什塔尔放在接下来吗？我们有……是的，密特拉（Mithras）对阵伊什塔尔。所以这是一场不错的对决，因为这实际上是一场纯粹的亚洲对决，对吧？嗯，我们或许可以讨论一下密特拉是否真的是波斯神。
So she's also known as Inanna. Inanna, right. And she's Sumerian, so incredibly old, much older than most of these gods. And again, has this huge continuity. So I'm not writing thinking that people think that Ishtar,
是的，好吧。但伊什塔尔绝对是美索不达米亚神。所以你是伊什塔尔的粉丝吗？我其实对伊什塔尔并不感冒，但一旦我读了关于伊什塔尔的资料，我发现她非常有趣。
because she's a goddess of love, that she inspired Aphrodite, that she's a kind of forerunner for Aphrodite. But you all know more about this than me, Tom. I don't know why I'm even talking. So Inanna is the patron goddess of Uruk, which is one of the very earliest cities, perhaps the earliest city.
所以她也被称为伊ナン纳（Inanna）。伊ナン纳，对。她是苏美尔人，所以极其古老，比大多数这些神都要古老得多。而且同样拥有这种巨大的连续性。所以我没有写错吧，人们认为伊什塔尔因为是爱神，所以启发了阿佛洛狄忒（Aphrodite），她可以说是阿佛洛狄忒的先驱。但你对这个的了解比我多，汤姆。我不知道为什么我还要开口。所以，伊ナン纳是乌鲁克（Uruk）的守护女神，乌鲁克是最早的城市之一，也许是最早的城市。
She then becomes the patron of Sargon of Akkad, who is kind of conventionally thought of as the first imperialist, the first man to carve out an empire. And he has a kind of Moses and the Bulrushes story. So he gets, you know, rather like Moses is, he gets cast out, gets rescued, works as a gardener. That's what you do. And then Ishtar falls in love with him and raises him up to become the greatest king in the world. And so that kind of basically makes her reputation as well.
她后来成为了阿卡德的萨尔贡（Sargon of Akkad）的守护神，萨尔贡通常被认为是第一位帝国主义者、第一个开创帝国的人。他有一个类似“摩西与芦苇丛”的故事。所以他——就像摩西一样——被抛弃了，被救了，当过园丁。这就是你所做的事。然后伊什塔尔爱上了他，把他扶植为世界上最伟大的国王。所以这基本上也奠定了她的名誉。
And the worship of her goes right the way through to assyria she's a great kind of patron of the assyrian kings and patron of the babylonian kings and again we you know we talked about chippy being the god of the harvest and of zits um in a rather similar way um ishtar is a war goddess so that's the role that she plays as the patron of assyria this terrifying militaristic empire but she's also the goddess of love. That's an interesting thing, isn't it, with a lot of these gods, that obviously their meaning changes over time.
对她的崇拜一直延续到亚述，她是亚述国王和巴比伦国王的伟大守护神。同样，我们之前讨论过奇皮托特克是丰收之神和……以一种相当类似的方式，伊什塔尔是一位战争女神——这就是她在作为恐怖的军国主义帝国亚述的守护神时所扮演的角色——但她也是爱神。这是一个有趣的现象，不是吗？对于许多神明来说，显然他们的含义随时间而改变。
But they take on different roles, don't they? I mean, we see this much later on with the Greek gods and goddesses, that they're almost imperialists in themselves and they sort of accumulate territory. They sort of absorb stuff. Yeah, they do. Yeah.
但他们承担了不同的角色，对吧？我的意思是，我们在后来的希腊神明身上也看到了这一点，他们本身几乎就是帝国主义者，他们会积累领土。他们会吞并各种东西。是的，他们确实如此。
And so Ishtar is the goddess of love. She kind of casts this erotic spell over Uruk. So Uruk is cast as, I suppose really it's the first metropolis to serve the role that cities have always played since, which is as a place where people come to experience the erotic in the way that they might not do in villages or out in the fields. And so again, the followers of Ishtar, you get this kind of haze
所以伊什塔尔是爱神。她在乌鲁克施放了一种色情的咒语。所以乌鲁克被塑造成——我想实际上它是第一大大都市，扮演着自古以来城市一直扮演的角色，那就是人们来这里体验色欲的地方，而这种体验在村庄或田野里可能是无法获得的。因此，同样地，伊什塔尔的追随者们，你会看到一种神话的迷雾，学者们还在争论它是真是假。但在很长一段时间里，人们认为伊什塔尔是圣洁卖淫（神圣妓女）的守护神。我认为现在人们普遍不认为这种事曾发生过。但你也会发现她的祭司们会女装男扮、男男发生性关系，所有这类报道都充斥着街头的交配……
of myth that scholars debate whether it's real or not. But for a long time, it's believed that Ishtar was the patroness of sacred prostitution. I think it's now not widely thought that that happened. But you also get her priests are cross-dressing, men sleeping with men, all this kind of stuff reports of copulation in the streets um and are these exaggerated do you think or are they are they real i don't know but there's a kind of sense of a kind of slight you know gay pride parade quality to her worship um which i think is i mean you know the sexual standards are completely different to ours but at the same time the sense that um you can obviously go beyond the bounds of the normal and
你觉得这些被夸大了吗，还是真实的？我不知道，但这有一种轻微的……你知道的，带有一点“同性恋骄傲大游行”特质的崇拜氛围。我认为这……我的意思是，那里的性标准与我们完全不同。但与此同时，那种认为你可以超越常规界限，如果你是个男人，你可以穿女装或与另一个男人睡觉等等，这种许可是由伊什塔尔赋予的，而这正是她权力的核心所在。她不是唯一一个这样做的神，对吧？我的意思是，我们还会遇到更多这样的神。所以总是存在着这样一个神的角色：赋予你某种特权。当你将自己与这个神联系在一起，或者当他们有节日之类的活动时，所有传统的规则都被暂停了，你可以随心所欲地做任何你想做的事。是的，绝对的。这也是乐趣的一部分。
if you're a man you can dress as a woman or sleep with another man or whatever is given license by by ishtar and that's the kind of the locus of her power she's not the only god that does that right i mean we're going to come across some more as well. So there's always a role of a god who gives you a license. When you associate yourself with this god or when they have a festival or something, all the traditional rules are suspended and you can kind of crack on and do whatever you like. Yeah, absolutely. And that's all part of the fun.
伊什塔尔是一位突破界限的女神。有一个著名的故事被讲了好几次，包括在著名的史诗《吉尔伽美什》中。这个故事的核心是，她有一个妹妹，是死神……伊什塔尔下去基本上是因为她想要制定——你刚才在谈论神如何吞并事物。伊什塔尔基本上也想接管死者的领域以及生者的领域。她穿过了七道门，在每一道门都丢下一些珠宝、衣服和权力的象征。她最终基本上变得赤身裸体、毫无力量，然后倒地身亡。地球上的每个人都失去了性欲。
And Ishtar is a goddess who pushes at the limits so there's a kind of famous story that gets told several times including in gilgamesh the famous epic but the core of the story is is that um she has a sister who's the goddess of the dead right and ishtar goes down essentially because she wants to enact you know you're talking about how gods annex things. Ishtar basically wants to kind of take over the realm of the dead as well as the realm of the living. And she goes through seven gates and at each gate she discards some jewelry, clothing, attributes of her power. She ends up basically naked and powerless and is struck down dead. Everybody on earth loses their libido.
所以这有点像古代的伟哥。没有人能够行房。安基（Enki），这位智慧之神，创造了这些具有性别流体特征的救援者，他们下去把她带了回来。她回来了，发现每个人都在哭泣——除了她的丈夫杜姆齐德（Dumuzid），他一直在花园里晃荡，根本不在乎。所以伊什塔尔对此极其愤怒，杀了他，把他送到冥界代替自己的位置，随后又感到后悔，试图把他弄回来。于是出现了一个类似于珀耳塞福涅（Persephone）的故事，他可以回来六个月与她团聚。
So it's a kind of anti-viagra right nobody nobody can perform Enki the the wise god creates these kind of gender fluid rescuers who go down and bring her back um she comes back she finds everyone is weeping um except for her husband um Dumuzid who he's kind of hanging out in the garden and he doesn't really care so ishtar is incredibly cross about that kills him sends him down to the underworld in her place regrets it tries to get him back and there's a kind of persephone story whereby he comes back for six months to be with her interesting yeah and that's another theme that comes up again and again in these God stories, isn't it?
有趣。这也是一个在这些神话故事中不断出现的主题，不是吗？死亡与重生，或者说生育力与某种……我的意思是，这显然与季节和所有诸如此类的事情有关，对吧？是的，关于伊什塔尔的最后一点是，尽管她在近东的基督教和伊斯兰教时期对她的崇拜逐渐消亡，但她有一个哥哥叫沙马什（Shamash），是太阳神。我曾去过伊拉克北部一个叫拉利什（Lalish）的地方，那里是雅兹迪人（Yazidis）这一宗教少数群体的圣地。这是一种高度融合的信仰，融合了犹太教、伊斯兰教、基督教和琐罗亚斯德教的元素。但他们有一个房间，一个供奉着一位名叫谢赫·沙姆斯（Sheikh Shams）的圣人的圣室。他在某种程度上与太阳有关。
Death and rebirth or the fertility and sort of, I mean, that's obviously associated with the seasons and all that sort of thing, isn't it? Yeah, and one last thing on Ishtar is that although her worship fades away in the Christian and the Muslim period in the Near East, she has a brother called Shamash, who is the God of the sun. And I went to a place called Lalish in northern Iraq, which is holy to the Yazidis, this kind of religious minority. And it's very syncretic faith, the kind of elements of Judaism and Islam and Christianity and Zoroastrianism, all kind of there. But they have a room, a chamber that is sacred to a holy man called Sheikh Shams. And he is in some way associated with the sun.
因此，有些学者认为这可能是通往沙马什的活生生的联系，从而也是通往伊什塔尔的联系，因为沙马什是伊什塔尔的哥哥。所以我认为这并不排除伊什塔尔的资格，因为我们在讨论沙马什而不是伊什塔尔。但这也许是伊拉克北部仍然存在的活生生的元素……这真是太美妙了。西蒙娜·德·波伏娃（Simone de Beauvoir）在《第二性》中是伊什塔尔的超级粉丝，她说伊什塔尔
And so there are scholars who think that this might be a living link to Shamash and therefore to Ishtar because Shamash is the brother of Ishtar. So I don't think that disqualifies Ishtar because we're talking about Shamash rather than Ishtar. But there is this perhaps living are elements that are still alive living elements still there in Northern Iraq which is kind of wonderful Simone de Beauvoir was a big fan of Ishtar in the second sex she says that Ishtar
被父权制的男性从历史中抹去了，女权主义者应该捍卫伊什塔尔。而她的观点被这样一个事实证明了：代表罗马士兵阶级的密特拉击败了她。这是一个典型的父权制阴谋。我想顺着这个话题，我们该休息一下了，对吧？我们大概真的应该这样。
has been written out of history by patriarchal men and that feminists should champion Ishtar and her case is proven by the fact that Mithras the gold of the Roman soldiery, beat her. It's a classic patriarchal manoeuvre. And I think on that note, we should go for a break, shouldn't we? We probably should, actually.
汤姆，我觉得我们聊得太多了。是的。但等我们休息回来后，我们会少聊一点，以更快的节奏聊完我们的神明。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）
I think we're talking too much, Tom. Yes. But when we come back after the break, we'll talk less and we'll move more quickly through our gods. See you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment
这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝秀场八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和现场门票的抢先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com，
we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com that's
网址是 therestisentertainment.com，这就是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。汤姆·霍兰德和我正在讨论诸神世界杯。我们已经讨论了摩洛克、奇皮托特克和伊什塔尔，现在，汤姆，轮到布丽吉特了。所以布丽吉特是一个有争议的选择，爱尔兰人，有些人会说她根本不是神。解释一下你自己。好的，所以布丽吉特是一个有争议的选择，爱尔兰人，有些人会说她根本不是神。解释一下你自己。好的，所以布丽吉特通常被视为一个“由神变成圣人”的例子，也就是基尔代尔的圣布丽吉特（Saint Bridget of Kildare），爱尔兰传统中伟大的圣人之一。是的，所以人们一直在争论圣布丽吉特是否存在，以及基本上当天主教徒向圣布丽吉特表达敬意时，他们实际上是在向一个异教神明表达敬意吗？因为这在早期基督教中经常发生吗？
therestisentertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back to the rest is history uh tom holland and i are discussing the world cup of gods we've talked about moloch chipitotec and ishtar and now tom bridget so bridget was a controversial choice irish some would say not a god um explain yourself okay so bridget was a controversial choice Irish some would say not a god explain yourself okay so Bridget is generally held up as an example of a god who becomes a saint so Saint Bridget of Kildare one of the great the great saints of the Irish tradition yeah and so people have debated whether Bridget Saint Bridget existed and essentially whether when Catholics pay their respects to Saint Bridget they're actually paying respect to a pagan god. Because did this happen a lot in early Christianity?
他们吸收了地方邪教之类的东西，作为一种……嗯，作为一种品牌收购之类的手段。嗯，自休谟（Hume）时代以来，这一直是针对天主教圣人崇拜的一种流行指控，休谟正是提出了这一点。关于布丽吉特曾是一个神的证据有……所以约克郡有一位女神叫布里甘蒂亚（Brigantia）。是的，我们知道她在英国受到崇拜，在邓弗里斯（Dumfries）发现了一座雕塑，上面刻有铭文，称她为布里甘蒂亚。因此，人们普遍认为布里甘蒂亚和布丽吉特名字相似，可能是同一个人。此外，在9世纪的爱尔兰，有一部名为《科马克词汇表》（Cormac's glossary）的著作，其中提到了布丽吉特是一位女神。她属于那种在9世纪已经逐渐淡出人们视野的爱尔兰神明万神殿。
They absorbed local cults and stuff as a sort of, well, as a sort of, you know, branding takeover kind of thing. Well, that's been a kind of popular accusation against the Catholic cult of saints since at least the time of Hume who makes exactly that point um and the evidence for for Bridget having been a god there are um so there's a god the goddess of Yorkshire Brigantia yeah we know that she's worshipped in Britain there's a sculpture found in in Dumfries with an inscription saying that she's called Brigantia and so um it's been popularly thought that Brigantia and Bridget, you know, similar names, maybe the same person. And also there is in the ninth century in Ireland, there is Cormac's glossary, it's called, refers to Bridget being a goddess. And she's part of this kind of pantheon of the Irish gods that has faded by the 9th century.
这就是这种想法的依据。她是一位诗人、一位治愈者、还是一位铁匠。是这样吗？是的，没错。她是一位三位一体的神。这是《科马克词汇表》上说的。是的。但还有另一种看待方式，
So that's the basis for thinking that. And she's a poet, she's a healer, and she's a smith. Is that right? That's right, yes. She's a tripartite god. That's what Cormac's glossary says. Yeah. But there is an alternative way of seeing it,
那就是认为，关于圣布丽吉特的证据实际上比曾有一个名叫布丽吉特的女神的证据要好得多。也许情况恰恰相反，也许是一位圣人突变成了一位女神，以至于人们开始认为——爱尔兰的编年史家开始认为这位女神曾经存在过。提出这种看法的理由在一篇非常有趣的论文中由一位名叫莉萨·巴特尔（Lisa Battelle）的学者提出。你可以在网上阅读它。所以它是公开的，非常值得一读。她的论点是，基尔代尔的布丽吉特确实存在，她完成了各种各样的神迹——人们相信她完成了各种各样的神迹——她出身非常卑微。她是一个奴隶的女儿。
which is to say that actually the evidence for Saint Bridget is much better than there having been a goddess called Bridget. And that perhaps actually it's the other way round, that perhaps you have a saint who mutates into a goddess so that people come to think that, you know, Irish chroniclers come to think that this goddess had existed. And the reason for thinking this is put forward in a very interesting paper by a scholar called Lisa Battelle. And you can read it online. So it's available, well worth reading. And her argument is that Bridget of Kildare did exist, that she performed all kinds, was believed to have performed all kinds of miracles, that she came from a very humble background. She was the daughter of a slave.
然而她最终却成了一个非常强大的人物……一个女修道院院长、修道院院长的朋友、国王的庇护人。因此，在如何刻画她的权力方面存在着挑战。所以有一些关于她的奇妙故事流传下来，比如她把斗篷挂在阳光上，她把水变成啤酒。我的意思是，这太绝了。你可以理解为什么她在阳光下如此受欢迎……是的，这是一个绝妙的细节。但这种方式……这是一个女性没有权力的时期。
And yet she ends up a very powerful figure that kind of, you know, an abbess, the friend of abbots, patron of kings. And so there is a challenge in working out how to portray her power. So there are stories that kind of wonderful stories that are told of her, that she hung her cloak on a sunbeam that she turned water into beer i mean brilliant stuff and you can see why she's kind of popular in our sunbeam yeah it's a wonderful detail um but the way to this is a period where women do not have power. Yeah. And the only example of women exercising power is in the dimension of the supernatural. And so St. Bridget comes to be associated with the attributes of gods.
女性行使权力的唯一范畴是在超自然领域。因此，圣布丽吉特开始与神明的属性联系在一起。所以她对风景、对动物、对大地、太阳和雨水所行使的权力。这些权力都是从消逝的异教传统中衍生出来的。所以当异教依然存在时，她就已经是一位圣人了。也就是说，爱尔兰当时还没有完全基督教化？基本上是这个论点吗？是的。她吸收了与女神相关的元素，因为这是基督教作家表达这位女性权力的唯一途径。
So the power that she exercises over the landscape, over the animals, over the earth and the sun and the rain. These are powers that kind of derive from the fading pagan traditions. So she's a saint at the same time as there are pagan. So Ireland is not yet fully Christianized. Is that basically the argument? Yeah. And she absorbs elements that are associated with goddesses because these are the only way that Christian writers can express the power of this woman.
因此，她对风景、对动物、对大地、太阳和雨水所施加的力量，这些力量在某种程度上源自逐渐消逝的异教传统。所以她既是一个圣徒，同时又存在着异教的成分。也就是说，爱尔兰尚未完全基督教化？这基本上就是他们的论点吗？是的。而且她吸收了与女神相关的元素，因为这是基督教作家表达这位女性力量的唯一途径。
Because otherwise, the idea that a woman could have power, spiritual power, is so strange that there is no other way of demonstrating it. So I think that that's a fascinating story. It's a good story, but it wasn't convincing to the Twitterati. No, it wasn't. Because she performed very... I mean, she was up against Apollo,
因为除此之外，女人能够拥有权力的这种想法，即拥有精神上的权力，是如此陌生，以至于没有其他方式来证明它。所以我认为这是一个引人入胜的故事。这是一个好故事，但未能说服推特上的那些精英们。不，确实没有。因为她的表现非常……我的意思是，她的对手是阿波罗，
and Apollo is kind of the Greek god's Greek god. But even. Because she performed very... I mean, she was up against Apollo and Apollo is kind of the Greek god's Greek god. But even so, she performed quite poorly, didn't she? I mean, did she even get 30% of the vote? I don't think she did, no.
而阿波罗可以说是希腊神明中的希腊神明。但即便如此。因为她的表现非常……我的意思是，她的对手是阿波罗，而阿波罗可以说是希腊神明中的希腊神明。但即便如此，她的表现还是相当糟糕，不是吗？我的意思是，她甚至得到了30%的选票吗？我认为她没有，真的没有。
Oh, Tom. No. So, it's a shame. So, she got knocked out. But I thought... I mean, that's an interesting story, isn't it? It is an interesting story.
哦，汤姆。没有。所以，这很遗憾。所以，她被淘汰了。但我觉得……我的意思是，这是一个有趣的故事，不是吗？这确实是一个有趣的故事。
It is. And you claimed, when you selected her, that there would be an interesting story. And and you claimed when you selected her that uh there would be an interesting story and the hands been so you've been vindicated even if no one voted for it um all right who've we got up next uh we got augustus augustus caesar now this is an interesting one because he quite patently is a man i mean and we are going to do a whole podcast i hope on augustus because i think he's clearly one of the two or three you know most important most effective most influential political leaders
确实是的。而且你当初挑选她的时候，曾断言这会是一个有趣的故事。而且你当初挑选她的时候，曾断言这会是一个有趣的故事，事实也确实如此，你已经被证明是正确的，哪怕根本没有人投她的票……好吧，接下来是谁呢？哦，我们有奥古斯都，奥古斯都·凯撒。这是一个很有意思的人物，因为他显然是一个男人，我的意思是，我希望我们能专门做一期播客来聊聊奥古斯都，因为我认为他显然是人类历史上两三个最重要、最有效、最有影响力的政治领袖之一，
in human history yeah the most in european history i would say the most in european history yeah i'm sure that's probably true i mean it's hard to think of anyone who would conceivably rival him actually um but so at what point is he deified he's deified after his death right he's not deified at the in his lifetime or not fully deified is that right well he's worshipped as a god outside rome but then he has he has his east i suppose no doubt yeah so in a in 8014 he dies his body is taken back to rome and they stage this incredible kind of pyrotechnical extravaganza with flames and I mean equivalent to fire
在人类历史上，对，在欧洲历史上，我会说是欧洲历史上影响最大的人，对，我确信这大概是真的，我的意思是很难想象有谁能真正与他匹敌……但是，那么他是在什么时候被神化的呢？他是在死后被神化的，对吧？他不是在生前被神化的，或者说没有完全被神化，是这样吗？嗯，他在罗马以外被当作神来崇拜，但随后他有……我想他有他的东方……毫无疑问，是的，所以在公元14年他去世了，他的遗体被运回罗马，他们举行了这场令人难以置信的、带有火焰的宏大烟火表演，我的意思是，这相当于一场大火。
so for people who don't know he is Octavian he is the adopted heir of Julius Caesar who was a god who had been deified and so one of the names he has this isn't a title it's his name his son of a god
所以对于不了解的人来说，他就是屋大维，他是尤利乌斯·凯撒的养子，而凯撒是一位曾经被神化的神，所以他所拥有的名字之一——这不是一个头衔，而是他的名字——就是“神之子”。
yeah so he's defeated Mark Antony and Cleopatra he's become the first emperor of Rome and created this new structure and then he's deified and that sort of
对，他击败了马克·安东尼和克丽奥佩特拉，成为了罗马的第一位皇帝，创建了这套新体制，然后他被神化了，这种……
he's picking up that tradition from Julius Caesar but then he's passing that on to all subsequent emperors they're all deified aren't they unless they're sort of driven out in
他继承了尤利乌斯·凯撒的传统，然后又将这一传统传递给后来的所有皇帝，他们都被神化了，不是吗？除非他们被赶下台……
no oh right okay no they're not they're sort of driven out in... No, no. Oh, right, okay. No, they're not. They're not. So Tiberius' son isn't, Caligula obviously isn't, Claudius is, Nero isn't. And so it basically depends whether you measure up or not.
不，哦，对，好吧。不，他们没有。他们只是被赶下台……不，不。哦，对，好吧。不，他们没有。他们没有。所以提比略的儿子没有，卡利古拉显然没有，克劳狄乌斯有，尼禄没有。所以这基本上取决于你的表现是否达标。
Well, if you're a successful emperor, you're deified then. Put it that way. Yes, yes. But Augustus is the kind of the archetype of the great emperor and therefore the archetype of an emperor who becomes deified so his very name augustus essentially it it signifies someone who's midway between earth and heaven so the the the sense that he is a supernatural figure a more than divine a more than human figure is there right the way from the time actually i mean basically from the moment
好吧，如果你是一位成功的皇帝，你就会被神化。这么说吧。是的，是的。但奥古斯都正是伟大皇帝的原型，因此也是一位得以神化的皇帝的原型，所以他的名字“奥古斯都”本身基本上就意味着一个介于凡间与天堂之间的人。因此，他是一个超自然人物、一个超越神明、超越人类的存在这种感觉，其实从一开始就一直存在，基本上就是从
that julius caesar is deified because augustus is his adopted son and that therefore in the opinion of the romans is his son he has this quality of the divine about him the name augustus gives him a further quality and by the the final year of his life you know he's starting to fall ill but there are all these kind of portents rumors around him showing that he's going to go to the heavens. And when he, at his funeral, a senator says that he has seen his spirit rising up to the sky and that's enough. So he gets enshrined as a god. And in the first century AD, this is by miles the fastest spreading cult. It's probably the fastest spreading cult across a broader range that history had ever seen, because everywhere in the Roman Empire, this cult is being instituted. And what's so fascinating about this though, Tom,
尤利乌斯·凯撒被神化的那一刻起，因为奥古斯都是他的养子，因此在罗马人看来他就是凯撒的儿子，他身上便带有一种神圣的特质。“奥古斯都”这个名字赋予了他更进一步的特质。到了他生命的最后一年，你知道，他开始生病，但在他周围出现了各种各样的预兆和传言，表明他将升入天堂。在葬礼上，一位参议员说他看到他的灵魂升上了天空，这就足够了。于是他被奉为神明。在公元一世纪，这绝对是传播速度最快的宗教狂热。它可能是有史以来在最广阔的范围内传播速度最快的信仰，因为在罗马帝国的每一个地方，这种对他的崇拜都在建立。但最引人入胜的地方在于，汤姆，
and what I think makes this in some ways a more fascinating story than almost any other of the contenders, is that it makes us rethink, you know, in the sort of 21st century, we think of mortal and immortal as two completely separate categories, don't we? The natural and supernatural, God and human. And most people who are atheists who are listening to this podcast will think, well, people in the past were very backward and they thought that they were strange creatures in the sky and all this sort of stuff. But Augustus' deification suggests a much more complicated relationship
而且我认为在某种程度上，这让这个故事比几乎所有其他竞争者的故事都更加引人入胜，那就是它让我们重新思考——你知道，在21世纪左右，我们将凡人和不朽视为两个完全不同的类别，对吧？自然与超自然，神与人。而听这个播客的绝大多数无神论者都会认为，过去的人非常落后，他们认为天空中存在着奇怪的生物等等诸如此类的事情。但奥古斯都被神化这件事暗示了一种远为复杂的关系，
between mortal and immortal. Because, of course, people didn't think he had powers. The people who had worked with him, who had been his civil servants, who had trudged in with the paperwork every morning and discussed tax policies, knew that they didn't think of him as a god in the sort of marvel superhero film
存在于凡人与不朽之间。因为，当然，人们并不认为他拥有法力。那些曾与他共事过的人，那些曾做过他的文官、每天早晨带着厚厚的文件蹒跚走来并讨论税收政策的人，非常清楚他们并不认为他是一个像漫威超级英雄电影里那样……
no sense of the gods did they it's a much more complicated nuanced picture than that it's about authority and about tradition and all this sort of stuff right i think it's also gratitude for because rome has been ravaged by civil war and augustus essentially is the man who brings peace so augustus is you know he's the son of a god he um he brings peace to a Augustus is, you know, he's the son of a God. He brings peace to a ravaged world. The people who support him proclaim this as, and we have inscriptions
没有任何神明那种概念，对吧？这是一种比那远为复杂、微妙的画面，它关乎权威、传统以及所有诸如此类的事情。对，我认为这也包含了感激之情，因为罗马饱受内战蹂躏，而奥古斯都基本上是那个带来和平的人。所以奥古斯都，你知道，他是神之子，他……他为这个饱受摧残的世界带来了和平。支持他的人将此宣告为——我们有碑文
saying it, that it's euangelia, so good news. Oh, interesting. Evangelical. Very interesting, yeah. And then when he dies, he goes to heaven
上面写着——这就是“福音”（euangelia），也就是好消息。哦，很有意思。福音派（Evangelical）。非常有意思，是的。然后当他死后，他去了天堂，
and sits at the right hand of his divine father. So there's nothing odd about that. The people of the Roman Empire take for granted that great people will, you know, can become gods. Lurking behind this, of course, is another cult that emerges in the first century of a son of a god who is a prince of peace, who ascends to heaven and sits at the right century of a son of a god who is a prince of peace who ascends to heaven and sits at the right hand of his father yes what what's shocking about the deification of jesus isn't isn't the fact that a mortal is becoming immortal but that a slave is doing someone who suffers immortal is a nobody rather than so there's a sense in which um so paul what saint
坐在他神圣父亲的右边。所以这没什么奇怪的。罗马帝国的臣民认为伟大的人将会、你知道的、能够成为神是理所当然的。潜藏在这一切背后的，当然还有另一个在公元一世纪兴起的崇拜：一个身为和平之君、升入天堂并坐在父亲右边的神之子……等等，公元一世纪一个身为和平之君、升入天堂并坐在父亲右边的神之子……是的，耶稣被神化真正令人震惊的地方，不在于一个凡人变成了不朽者，而在于一个奴隶在做……一个遭受折磨的不朽者是一个无名小卒，而不是……所以从某种意义上说，呃，所以保罗，当圣
paul when he goes to galatia you know he his letter to the Galatians. Galatians seems to have been a particular cult center for Augustus. A lot of what we know about Augustus, his autobiography, the accounts of that come from Galatia. And so there's a sense, I think, in which Paul certainly is very aware of the fact that the euangelion, the gospel, the good news that he's bringing is a parody of the cult of augustus but also before we move on isn't isn't augustus's cult like well like julius caesar's cult they're clearly picking up aren't they on the sort of hellenistic so alexander the great had been a god philip the second of macedon alexander's father had had god-like attributes the ptolemies in egypt had been worshipped as gods as as pharaohs had, and that the Romans are basically picking up, as their empire has expanded and they've moved into the
保罗前往加拉太时，你知道，他写给加拉太人的信。加拉太似乎一直是奥古斯都崇拜的一个特殊中心。我们对奥古斯都的了解、他的自传以及相关的记录，很大一部分都来自加拉太。因此，我认为在某种程度上，保罗肯定非常清楚这样一个事实：他所带来的福音（euangelion）、好消息，是对奥古斯都崇拜的一种戏仿。但在此之前，奥古斯都的崇拜难道不是——就像尤利乌斯·凯撒的崇拜一样——它们显然是在吸收希腊化时期的传统吗？比如亚历山大大帝曾是一位神，马其顿的腓力二世（亚历山大的父亲）也拥有神一般的特质，埃及的托勒密王朝曾被当作神来崇拜，就像法老一样。随着罗马帝国的扩张，他们进入了
eastern Mediterranean, aren't they picking up a lot of that sort of stuff and then transporting it back to Rome in place of the sort of slightly more republican, kind of Cato-ish values that they'd had before that? I think part of the appeal of the cult is that different people, different people's different traditions can project their cultural understandings onto the figure of of this deified emperor yeah um so i think yeah i think i think that's very interesting i think augustus was you know absolutely deserved his presence in the in this world cup but again he crashed out didn't he crashed out to very poorly very in a theme of the number one seed. I think
地中海东部，难道他们不是吸收了大量这种文化，然后将其带回罗马，以取代他们先前那种稍微更偏向共和制、偏向加图式（Cato-ish）的价值观吗？我认为这种崇拜的吸引力之一在于，不同的人、不同人群的不同传统，可以将他们各自对文化的理解投射到这位被神化的皇帝身上。是的，呃，所以我认为，是的，我认为这非常有趣。我认为奥古斯都绝对当得起他在这次世界杯上的席位，但同样地，他惨遭淘汰了，不是吗？他表现非常糟糕地出局了，完全符合头号种子选手的魔咒。我想
it was always going to be a difficult match for him. A lot of the fans just couldn't see past the fact that he had once been a man. Yeah. Now, who are we going to do next? Are we going to do... We've got Loke against Anubis. So this is the big shock. And I still think...
对当时的场面来说，这对他而言注定是一场艰难的比赛。许多粉丝只是无法逾越这样一个事实：他曾经只是一个凡人。好啦，接下来我们要选谁？我们要选……我们有洛基对阵阿努比斯。所以这是一场巨大的冷门。我依然认为……
I mean, I voted for Anubis. I wanted Anubis. I'm not going to lie. I wanted Anubis to win because of my own association with him at school when I made my Anubis mask. I was very proud of it. However, Loki is a very interesting god, and he probably should have gone further in the tournament. Do you not think?
我的意思是，我投给了阿努比斯。我想要阿努比斯赢，我不会撒谎。我希望阿努比斯赢，因为我在上学时制作过阿努比斯面具，对它有着特殊的情结。我当时为之感到非常自豪。然而，洛基是一位非常有趣的神，他本应该在锦标赛中走得更远。你不这么认为吗？
Surprised he lost. It's a sort of anti-Tom Hiddleston, though, isn't it? Anti-Marvel Comics backlash, I think. Do you think? Because I think that Odin and Loki are well-known, perhaps better known than any other god at the moment because of that Marvel dimension. I think maybe people are a bit bored of him because he's ubiquitous.
我很惊讶他输了。这有点像对汤姆·希德勒斯顿（Tom Hiddleston）的反弹，不是吗？我认为这是对漫威漫画的一种反感。你觉得呢？因为我觉得奥丁和洛基广为人知，由于漫威宇宙的影响，他们可能比现在任何其他神明都更为人所知。我想也许人们有点厌倦他了，因为他无处不在。
Maybe. There's about to be a Loki film or TV series or something, and I think he's just everywhere, and there's trailers for it a lucky film or tv series or something and i think it's just everywhere and there's trailers for all the time and it's a kind of fascinating example of the way in which this in a sense is still a living tradition i suppose so well because you know notoriously what we know about the the gods of the vikings and and is is mediated through writers who are christian by the time they'reic writers. And so therefore the issue is always how Christianised has this been
也许吧。马上就要上映一部洛基电影或电视剧什么的，我觉得他真是无处不在，到处都是关于它的预告片……一部洛基电影或电视剧什么的，我觉得他真是无处不在，到处都是关于它的预告片。这是一个引人入胜的例子，说明了这种信仰在某种程度上仍然是一种活生生的传统，我想是的。因为你知道，众所周知，我们对维京人诸神的了解，是通过那些在当时已经是基督教徒的作家们的笔墨才得以流传下来的。因此，这里的问题始终是：这究竟被基督教化了多少，
or are these authentic traditions? And in a sense, so it's always being rewritten, rewritten, rewritten. And their kind of iteration in the Marvel comics is just another example of that. I suppose that's true. Well, anyway, Loki, so he's a trickster. A lot of people will know
还是说这些是正宗的传统？从某种意义上说，它一直在被重写、重写、重写。他们在漫威漫画中的演绎，只是这种现象的又一个例子。我想这倒也没错。好吧，不管怎样，洛基是一个恶作剧之神。许多人会知道，
that he's the father of Hel and Fenrir the wolf and Jormungandr the serpent, that he's also bizarrely the father of Sleipnir, is it? The eight-legged horse. The eight-legged horse of Odin. Yes. Loki is impregnated. He is impregnated himself and gives birth to this this eight-legged horse i mean that's a very peculiar even by the standards of ancient gods that's a that's a strange carry-on isn't it and then of course famously he tricks hod into the blind brother of balder of balder
他是海拉（Hel）、巨狼芬里尔（Fenrir）和巨蛇耶梦加得（Jormungandr）的父亲，而且诡异的是，他还是斯雷普尼尔（Sleipnir）的父亲，对吧？那匹八足马。奥丁的八足马。是的。洛基怀孕了。他自己怀孕了，并生下了这匹八足马。我的意思是，即便以古代神明的标准来看，这也极其奇特，这是一件很诡异的事，对吧？然后，当然，众所周知，他诡计多端地诱骗巴德尔（Balder）的盲眼兄弟霍德（Hod）
and shooting balder the god who everybody loves and then he's punished for that, isn't he? Does a serpent drip venom into his face? Is that it? Yeah, well, there's an intermediate stage because he, the god of the underworld says that Balder can come back if it's shown that everyone is weeping for him. And everyone across creation weeps for him, except for a giantess.
射杀巴德尔——那个所有人挚爱的神——然后他因此受到了惩罚，不是吗？是不是有一条毒蛇将毒液滴到他脸上？是这样吗？是的，不过这中间还有一个阶段，因为冥界之神说，如果能证明所有人都在为巴德尔哭泣，巴德尔就可以回来。万物众生都为他哭泣，除了一个女巨人。
And the gods ask, why are you not weeping? And he says, the giantess says, I don't care. It's like the person who refuses to go to Diana's funeral or something. Yeah. But that turns out to be Loki. And so then they seize him. They seize him and chain him down and put a serpent who drips poison on his head.
众神问她：“你为什么不哭？”那个女巨人回答说：“我才不在乎呢。”这就好比有人拒绝去参加黛安娜王妃的葬礼一样。是的。但事实证明，那个女巨人就是洛基。于是他们抓住了他。他们抓住他并将他锁起来，放了一条毒蛇在他头上滴毒液。
So what's all this, Tom? So this is a very unusual figure because most of the gods we've talked about are people who were, you know, you'd associate yourself with their cult because there was something admirable about the god or they incarnated some value, you know, love or fertility or whatever. But he's a pretty malignant presence, isn't he? He's fun, isn't he? I suppose he is fun. I mean, he's in pretty malignant presence, isn't he? He's fun, isn't he? I suppose he is fun. I mean, he's in the kids' stories. So, you know, our house is full of creaking with the weight of kind of Norse myths and stuff.
汤姆，这到底是怎么回事？所以这是一个非常不寻常的人物，因为我们讨论过的大多数神明，都是那些你会与其崇拜产生共鸣的存在，因为这些神明身上有令人钦佩的地方，或者他们体现了某种价值观，比如爱、生育力等等。但他是一个相当恶毒的存在，不是吗？他很有趣，不是吗？我想他确实很有趣。我的意思是，他存在于儿童故事中。所以，你知道的，我们的房子里塞满了厚重的北欧神话之类的东西。
And he's always in them. I mean, when he's not in them, they're very boring. It's Thor hitting a giant with a hammer. And sometimes he's helping Thor out, isn't he? Yes, he is. Sometimes Thor is an absolute fool. And Loki's there to... I mean, he's kind of divine Odysseus, basically.
而且他总是出现在这些故事里。我的意思是，当他不在的时候，故事就会变得非常无聊。那就是雷神托尔用锤子砸巨人。而且有时他也在帮托尔的忙，不是吗？是的，他确实在帮。有时托尔简直是个大傻瓜。而洛基就在那里去……我的意思是，他基本上就是神界的奥德修斯。
Yes, yeah. And people like, you know... Well, that's why the Hiddleston portrayal. I mean, he's much more interesting than Thor in the Marvel Comics films. You know, Thor is just a sort of beefcake, and Hiddleston is playing this sort of charismatic, sort of smirking... Clever person. Yeah, I mean, so that makes it weird that he did crash out, actually.
是的，是的。人们喜欢，你知道的……嗯，这就是为什么希德勒斯顿的塑造会那么成功。我的意思是，在漫威漫画电影中，他比托尔有趣得多。你知道，托尔只是一块肌肉发达的健美身材，而希德勒斯顿扮演的是这种富有魅力、带着一丝坏笑的……聪明人。是的，我的意思是，这让人觉得他居然出局了很奇怪，实际上。
But again, I think that's a sort of... But people love dogs. I mean, people like tricksters, but they like dogs even more. They're not quite enough, as we found out later in the tournament. Well, we'll come to that. It's a big controversy of the tournament, but we'll save that. Okay, so that was Loki gone. And then we have Kibale.
但话说回来，我觉得这是一种……不过人们都喜欢狗。我的意思是，人们喜欢恶作剧之神，但他们更喜欢狗。正如我们在锦标赛后期所发现的那样，这些还远远不够。好吧，我们待会儿会谈到那个。那是锦标赛中的一个巨大争议，但我们先留到后面说。好吧，洛基出局了。接下来我们有库柏勒（Cybele）。
Right. Yeah. Again, one of your choices. Yes. Now, I was mystified by this choice until I did some research and found out about the priests or the associates of Kibale. But did you find out how old she is? Very old.
对。是的。同样，这也是你的选择之一。是的。现在，我对这个选择感到十分困惑，直到我做了一些研究，才了解了库柏勒的祭司或追随者们。不过，你查过她有多古老吗？非常古老。
You talked about how old Ishtar is. Kibale is older. Is Kibale older? Well, maybe. But it's possible that she goes all the way back to Çatalhöyük. So Kibale is a Phrygian god in Anatolia, what's now Turkey. Turkey, yeah. But it is thought that her cult ultimately has its origins in the figure of a mother goddess
你之前谈到过伊什塔尔有多古老。库柏勒还要古老。库柏勒更古老吗？嗯，也许吧。但她很有可能一直追溯到恰塔霍长（Çatalhöyük）。所以库柏勒是安纳托利亚（也就是现在的土耳其）的一个弗里吉亚神。土耳其，是的。但人们认为，她的崇拜最终起源于一个母神形象，
who is associated with these kind of very, very fat women found at Çatalhöyük, which is this kind of incredibly ancient city. Because the statues are very very fat aren't they of her yeah so it's kind of 6000 bc something like that and considering that you know she's worshipped right the way up to kind of 500 ad she if if that's the case then she is the deity that has been worshipped longer than any other so she's been worshipped almost. Much longer than, say, the Jewish three times longer than Jesus so far, which is
她与恰塔霍长出土的那些非常非常肥胖的女性形象有关，那是一个极其古老的城市。因为出土的那些关于她的雕像非常非常胖，对吧？是的，所以大约是公元前6000年左右，诸如此类。考虑到——你知道的——她一直被崇拜到公元500年左右，如果真是这样的话，那么她就是被崇拜时间最长的神明，没有之一。所以她被崇拜的时间几乎……比方说，比犹太人的时间长得多，到目前为止比耶稣的长了三倍，这
extraordinary when you think of it. So we talked about Akhenaten and Tutankhamen. They are closer to us than they are to them. The first worshippers of Kybala. So I think she deserves an absolute veteran. And she's a mother goddess. But what's interesting, the Romans adopted her, didn't. And she's a sort of, she's a mother goddess.
细想起来真是非同寻常。所以我们讨论过阿肯那顿和图坦卡蒙。他们距离我们的时间，比他们距离库柏勒最初的崇拜者的距离还要近。所以我认为她绝对当得起资深老将的称号。她是一位母神。但有趣的是，罗马人接纳了她，不是吗？她是一位母神。
But what's interesting, the Romans adopted her, didn't they? During the Punic War, they brought some stone to Rome. Yeah, so they get told, so they're fighting the war against Hannibal and they get told to bring the cult of Cybele to Rome. And the ship gets stuck and a noble Roman virgin helps pull it up. And there's a famous painting by Mantegna illustrating that in the National Gallery. Pres gallery presumably not single-handed i mean she doesn't that's that's the yeah that's the and at some point is kibble got the face of a stone is that right there's all because she's i think because she's a mother goddess yeah and every cult has you know every
但有趣的是，罗马人接纳了她，不是吗？在布匿战争期间，他们把一些圣石带到了罗马。是的，所以他们得到神谕——当时他们正在与汉尼拔作战，他们被告知要将库柏勒的崇拜引入罗马。结果船卡住了，一位高贵的罗马处女帮忙把它拉了上去。国家美术馆里有一幅曼特尼亚（Mantegna）绘制的描绘这一幕的名画。珍藏画廊里大概吧，当然不是她一个人拉的——我的意思是她并没有……那是，那是……是的，这就是那个传说。而且在某个时刻，库柏勒长着一块石头的脸，对吧？这一切都是因为她是一位母神，是的，每种信仰都有——你知道的，每个人
everyone has a mother goddess yeah she can kind of blur in very easily. And so lots of the statues of Cybele, you know, they're done by Greek sculptors. And so she looks like any Greek god. But there are also these much older traditions where she is associated just with stones or with totems or whatever and the stories that are told about kibble are very unlike greek gods really there's there's a kind of strangeness to it um so essentially there's there's this thing where she before she becomes kibble she is hermaphroditic. And she then cuts off her testicles. Right.
都有一个母神——所以她可以很容易地与其他人融为一体。因此，库柏勒的许多雕像，你知道的，都是由希腊雕塑家制作的。所以她看起来就像任何一个希腊神明一样。但也有一些更古老的传统，在那里她只与石头、图腾或诸如此类的东西联系在一起。关于库柏勒的故事与希腊神话非常不同，里面有一种诡异的色彩。呃，基本上有这样一个传说：在她成为库柏勒之前，她是双性同体的。然后她割下了自己的睾丸。没错。
Hacks them off and we're back into the genital mutilation. Yeah, we're going to get a bit more of this in a second. These testicles then grow up to become a fruit tree. A river nymph takes the fruit, puts it to her breast, and becomes pregnant with this fruit. Gives birth to this beautiful youth who's given the name of Attis. Okay, yeah. Kibale then falls in love with Attis, who in a sense is her son.
残忍地割掉了它们，我们又回到了生殖器割除的话题。是的，我们待会儿还会听到更多这方面的内容。这些睾丸后来长成了一棵果树。一位河中仙女摘下了果实，把它放在胸前，并因此怀上了这个果实。她生下了这个俊美的少年，并给他取名为阿蒂斯（Attis）。好吧，是的。随后，库柏勒爱上了阿蒂斯，从某种意义上说，阿蒂斯是她的儿子，
We're the product of her own testicles that have been turned into a tree. Yes, and a fruit. Yes. Attis wants to marry someone. Kibale is jealous, turns up at the marriage. Yeah. Attis goes mad, cuts off his his testicles runs away from the altar and kibale then basically keeps him in kind of suspended animation so it's the worst wedding ever that makes that that makes the wedding for the game of thrones like a battle that's a gate
是我们自己的睾丸变成树后结出的果实。是的，还有果实。是的。阿蒂斯想娶别人。库柏勒心生嫉妒，出现在婚礼上。是的。阿蒂斯发疯了，割掉了自己的睾丸，从圣坛前逃跑了，然后库柏勒基本上让他处于一种悬浮状态——所以这是史上最糟糕的婚礼，这让《权力的游戏》里的婚礼看起来就像是一场……那真是一场血色婚礼（gate walk）——我的意思是，想象一下，如果你是新娘，而你的新郎突然割掉了自己的睾丸，并和他的母亲私奔了。
walk i mean imagine if you're the bride and your groom suddenly hacks off his testicles and runs off with his mother. That didn't go. It's a terrible, it's a terrible, terrible business. Oh, my God. So you can see why the Romans are slightly sniffy about it. Yeah, but then they adopt it. They're like, they're losing a war. They think, well, what's the obvious thing to do?
那可真是不对劲。这真是一桩糟糕透顶、糟糕透顶、糟糕透顶的勾当。哦，天哪。所以你可以理解为什么罗马人对她有点不屑一顾了。是的，但他们后来还是接纳了她。他们就像是——他们在输掉一场战争，他们想，好吧，最显而易见该做的是什么？
Let's adopt this really mad religion. Yeah, but they're adopting this kind of stone element they're not adopting all the weird shit that goes with it yeah but then am i not right in thinking that they do adopt the priests and the priests i mean this is obviously why you chose it because you love the subject of genital mutilation the priests are called the galley aren't they and they have yes the day of the of blood, as they call it. Never a very appealing prospect, I think, in a religious... First of all, the day of blood. Anyway, there's a day of blood. Sorry, I know we shouldn't be laughing in our own podcast.
让我们信奉这个疯狂透顶的宗教吧。是的，但他们接纳的是那种石头的元素，他们并没有接纳与之俱来的所有那些疯狂的破事。是的，不过我没记错的话，他们确实接纳了她的祭司，而那些祭司——这显然就是你选择她的原因，因为你热爱生殖器割除这个主题——那些祭司被称为伽利（Galli），对吧？他们确实有……是的，他们所谓的“血腥之日”。这在宗教活动中从来都不是一个太吸引人的前景，我想……首先，是血腥之日。不管怎样，有一个血腥之日。抱歉，我知道我们不该在我们自己的播客里笑。
They wave this. It's not funny. I mean, they're chopping off the testicles they wave tambourines around they have a dance and then they mutilate themselves roaming the streets um and so they they spread um westwards to rome and the romans are very disapproving of this and the romans have adopted the cult of Cuba, but they don't approve of these auto-castrating, cross-dressing priests. No. And Seneca says something to the tune of, you know, a cult that requires people to do this
他们挥舞着这个。这可一点也不好笑。我的意思是，他们切除睾丸，挥舞着手鼓，跳着舞，然后进行自我残害，在街头游荡……呃，所以他们向西传播到了罗马，而罗马人对此非常不赞成。罗马人虽然接纳了库柏勒的崇拜，但他们并不赞同这些会进行自我阉割、身穿女装的祭司。不。塞内加（Seneca）曾大意说过，一个需要人们这样做才能维持的宗教，
isn't a cult that's worth having. He's not wrong, to be fair. I mean, I think... Well, I... I mean, if it's that that i mean if you had the choice at the time of that or the cult of augustus and what you have to do in the cult of augustus or of course the cult of christ and in the long run it's it's the worship of christ that blocks out the worship of kibble and julian the apostate is really the last
根本不值得拥有。说实话，他说得没错。我的意思是，我觉得……好吧，我……我的意思是，如果当时让你在那个信仰与奥古斯都的崇拜之间做出选择——在奥古斯都的崇拜中你必须做什么，或者当然还有对基督的崇拜——从长远来看，正是对基督的崇拜压倒了对库柏勒的崇拜。背教者尤利安（Julian the Apostate）其实是最后一个
significant figure who who's a big fan of kible. Is he? The nephew of Constantine brought up a Christian, repudiates Christianity, goes back to the worship of Cybele and goes to the great shrine of Cybele. And he's very disappointed to find that it's basically been abandoned. And he writes letters to the priests of Cybele saying, why aren't you handing out alms to the poor and doing charitable work? And the reason for that is that priests of Cybele are too busy hacking off their testicles and roaming the streets dressed as women. And obviously the church doesn't really approve of that. And so it gets phased out. If we had the World Cup now with people having listened to this,
坚定喜爱库柏勒的重要人物。是吗？他是君士坦丁的侄子，由基督教抚养长大，后来背弃了基督教，重新回到了对库柏勒的崇拜，并前往库柏勒的大神殿。结果他非常失望地发现，那里基本上已经被废弃了。他给库柏勒的祭司写信说，你们为什么不向穷人施舍、不做慈善工作呢？原因就在于，库柏勒的祭司们正忙着割掉自己的睾丸，穿着女装在街上游荡。而教会显然并不太赞同这一点。所以这种崇拜逐渐消亡了。如果我们现在举办世界杯，在人们听了这些之后，
Cybele might do better. Anyway, from one very wacky god to another the last god of this podcast anyway and then we'll do the others in our follow-up podcast the other person who crashed out in the first round of course was prince philip huge disappointment to me and i know to you yes i was gutted that prince philip i thought prince philip would do well um he didn't he was beaten by dionysus wasn't he? Quite comfortably, actually. But Dominic, tell us why we included Prince Philip. Well, Prince Philip is, or was, worshipped. He was worshipped on the island of Tanna,
库柏勒也许会表现得更好。不管怎样，从一个极其古怪的神转向另一个——无论如何，这也是本期播客的最后一位神明，接下来的其他神明我们会在后续的播客中讨论。在第一轮比赛中惨遭淘汰的另一个人，当然就是菲利普亲王（Prince Philip），这对我来说是个巨大的失望，我也知道这对你而言也是。是的，菲利普亲王的落选让我痛心疾首，我曾以为菲利普亲王会表现得很出色……他并没有，他被狄奥尼索斯（Dionysus）击败了，不是吗？而且赢得相当轻松。但是，多米尼克，告诉我们为什么要将菲利普亲王纳入其中。嗯，菲利普亲王曾经是——或者说现在依然是——被崇拜的对象。他在塔纳岛（Tanna）上受到崇拜，
which is part of Vanuatu, by the Yaonan tribe. So this is what's called a cargo cult, which probably a lot of our listeners will have heard of. So they mainly flourished in kind of Melanesia in the Pacific after the Second World War. And, I mean, the way to think of it is you have all these islands where the sort of tribes are living often untouched, relatively untouched by the outside world.
该岛是瓦努阿图的一部分，由亚奥南（Yaonan）部落供奉。这就是所谓的“货物崇拜”（cargo cult），我们的许多听众可能都听说过。这种崇拜主要在二战后太平洋的美拉尼西亚一带兴起。我的意思是，理解它的方式是这样的：在所有这些岛屿上，各个部落常常过着未被触及、或相对未被外界触及的生活。
Around about the period of the Second World War, obviously they're visited by lots of Japanese American soldiers who have a lot of stuff and and the stuff often gets left behind or the stuff washes up on beaches and you have what's called cargo cults so the most famous one concerns a character called John Frum and some anthropologists think that John from means John from America or whatever. And people on the islands, not unreasonably, thought these visitors from another world have come with all this sort of incredible baffling stuff. And one day they will come back and they will bring more stuff.
大约在二战期间，显然有许多日本士兵和美国士兵来到这里，他们携带着大量的物资，而这些物资经常被遗弃，或者被冲上海滩。于是就有了所谓的“货物崇拜”。其中最著名的一个涉及一个名叫“约翰·弗伦”（John Frum）的人物，一些人类学家认为“John from”的意思就是“来自美国的约翰”（John from America）或诸如此类。岛上的人们并非不合情理地认为，这些来自另一个世界的访客带着所有这些令人难以置信的、匪夷所思的物资来到了这里。总有一天，他们会再次归来，并带来更多的物资。
And they are like visitors from another plane they are like supernatural visitors so prince philip is is well prince philip went to vanuatu in the queen went to vanuatu i think in 1974 and you know how exactly the prince philip cult started is unclear um it's probably connected with that visit in the 70s. They might slightly predate it. If I am being very sceptical, I would say that the single biggest driver of this cult is the fact that every two years,
他们就像来自另一个维度的访客，就像超自然的来客。所以菲利普亲王是——嗯，菲利普亲王去过瓦努阿图，女王也去过瓦努阿图，我想是在1974年。菲利普亲王崇拜具体是如何开始的，目前还不清楚……它可能与70年代的那次访问有关。不过这种崇拜可能在此之前就略有存在。如果我要保持高度的怀疑态度，我会说推动这种崇拜的最大单一动力其实是这样一个事实：每隔两年，
people from the newspapers arrive in this village and say to these guys, can you please pose with a picture of Prince Philip? Yes. Amused readers of the Daily Telegraph. And documentaries they make, didn't they? They had a documentary about them. Channel 4 brought some of them to England.
报社的人们就会来到这个村庄，对这些当地人说：“你们能和菲利普亲王的照片合个影吗？”是的。《每日电讯报》（Daily Telegraph）那些觉得好玩的读者。他们还拍摄过纪录片，不是吗？他们拍过关于他们的纪录片。第四频道（Channel 4）把其中一些人带到了英国。
And they met Prince Philip. And they met Prince Philip. Now, it may well be, if I'm being completely sceptical, that once the cameras were off and the doors were closed, the tribesmen said to Prince Philip, we're actually perfectly aware that you're not a god, but we fancied the trip to London. I mean, I might be wrong.
他们见到了菲利普亲王。他们见到了菲利普亲王。现在，完全秉持怀疑态度的话，很可能的情况是，一旦摄像机关上、房门关闭，部落成员就会对菲利普亲王说：“其实我们心里很清楚你并不是什么神，但我们挺想去伦敦旅游一趟的。”我的意思是，也许我猜错了。
I might be being too cynical. Actually, they may well believe it. So Prince Philip, again, there was a lot of discussion about this in the sports forums. So there was a comment from Jeff Hannum. I wonder if Prince Philip has offended the other gods yet. Well, yes. Interesting question.
也许我表现得过于愤世嫉俗了。事实上，他们可能真的深信不疑。所以菲利普亲王——同样地，体育论坛上对此有过很多讨论。杰夫·汉纳姆（Jeff Hannum）曾发表过一条评论：“我不知道菲利普亲王是否已经冒犯了其他神明。”嗯，是的。这是一个有趣的问题。
I mean, you wouldn't want to offend Chippy, would you? No, but I think Prince Philip had seen a lot in his life i think he could cope with you know he'd he'd had an interesting life in himself or maybe kibble's more outlandish cult would be a bit much for him so gareth arden makes exactly this point talking about prince philip seriously he does have a good god-like backstory he fled homeland during perilous war so like an es i suppose yeah married the queen her father became king after a dynastic squabble of a global empire chariot racer sort of because he yes talked about this trapping or whatever it's called yeah um a great athlete played cricket marksman shot pheasants thrill seeker crashed land rover so yeah i mean when when prince philip died
我的意思是，你肯定不想得罪奇比（Chippy）吧？不，但我认为菲利普亲王一生中经历过很多风雨，我想他应付得来——他自己的人生就已经足够丰富多彩了。或者也许库柏勒那种更奇诡的崇拜对他来说会稍微过分了一点。加雷思·阿登（Gareth Arden）恰恰提出了这一点，他在严肃讨论菲利普亲王时说：他的确有着极佳的、神明般的背景故事——在充满危险的战争中逃离故土，所以就像伊阿宋（Jason）一样，我想是的；娶了女王，女王的父亲在经历了一场全球帝国的王朝争夺后成为了国王；战车赛手——差不多是这样，因为他——是的，谈到过这种双轮马车（trapping）还是别的什么来着，是的；一位伟大的运动员，打板球，神枪手，猎取野鸡，追求刺激的人，撞毁过陆虎汽车……所以，是的，我的意思是，当菲利普亲王去世时，
i didn't really know very much about him i just thought he was kind of vaguely boring royal. But he was definitely one of those people who the more I read his obituaries, the more interesting I realised he was. And I think he would make a good god. He would make a brilliant deified Roman emperor, wouldn't he? He probably made a very good Roman emperor. I mean, he looked like could have gone imperial. Well, the thing that Geoff Hannam's saying about has Prince Philip offended other gods? I mean,
我其实对他的了解并不多，我只觉得他是一个模模糊糊、有些无趣的王室成员。但随着我阅读他的讣告越多，我越发意识到他是一个多么有趣的人。我认为他会成为一个很好的神。他会成为一个绝佳的被神化的罗马皇帝，不是吗？他大概会是一个非常优秀的罗马皇帝。我的意思是，他看起来确实有那种帝王之风。好吧，杰夫·汉纳姆提到的关于“菲利普亲王是否冒犯了其他神明”的问题，我的意思是，
that kind of quality of the acerbic, I think is a central quality for a god because they can't just be, yeah, they've got to have
那种尖锐刻薄的特质，我认为是神明的一大核心特质，因为他们不能只是……是的，他们必须
a whiff of danger about them. A god, I don't think, should have any consideration for sort of health and safety considerations
自带一种危险的气息。我认为，神明不应该对任何健康与安全方面的考量
or human resources. No, I would say that if there's a lesson to be drawn from our study of the gods in this World Cup, a concern with health and safety considerations or human resources? No, I would say that if there's a lesson to be drawn from our study of the gods in this World Cup, a concern with health and safety does not feature. And I think that that's a good note on which to end this episode. The eight losers.
或人力资源有什么顾忌。不，我要说的是，如果从我们对这次世界杯中诸神的研究中可以吸取什么教训的话，那就是对健康与安全考量或人力资源的关注是根本不存在的。我认为这是一个为本期节目画上句号的好地方——这八位失败者。
And in our next episode, we're going to talk about the last eight and we will get through to the and reveal the champion for those of you who don't already know. So we will just see you on the next podcast. Cheerio. Bye bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
在我们的下一期节目中，我们将讨论最后八强，我们将一路挺进并揭晓最终的冠军，对于那些还不知道结果的人来说。所以我们就在下一期播客中见吧。再见。拜拜。感谢收听《历史其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告收听
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及加入我们的聊天社群，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。